for the better part of a year now public
schools in san francisco have refused to
educate
children they've kept classrooms closed
but that doesn't mean they aren't
doing anything they're very busy they
just voted to rename
44 schools because the names were racist
now how are these names racist many
names were people who weren't racist in
fact were strongly against racism like
most americans are
so why did they do it well the school
board made the mistake of putting their
reasoning
for each name change in a spreadsheet
you should take a look at the
spreadsheet
it's incredible how stupid these people
are the ones in charge of the schools
here's one example abe lincoln's name
was scrubbed from a high school because
of quote
rampant corruption in the indian office
in his administration again
this is the guy who ended slavery our
16th president
who signed the emancipation proclamation
he's gone corruption of the indian
office
then they wanted to scrub dianne
feinstein's name from an elementary
school dianne feinstein what was her
name on a school
anyway she's some mediocre senator but
they're taking it off now
she's not woke enough if dianne
feinstein is not woke enough for you
what's your school district like